debajo de los puentes de trípoli decenas
de migrantes esperan todos los días a
sus potenciales clientes para que los
ocupen en trabajos de construcción
mecánica o cualquier servicio por el que
puedan recibir un poco de dinero
eritreos nigerianos y sudaneses se
volvieron parte de la columna vertebral
de la economía informal libia todos
abandonaron sus países por los
conflictos la pobreza o falta de
oportunidades
ahora están varados en este país
norteafricano donde la situación tampoco
es mejor
libia se ha convertido en un centro de
emigración irregular de todos aquellos
que no lograron atravesar el
mediterráneo para llegar a europa
llegado vine a libia me quedé en
misurata y trípoli para trabajar y ganar
dinero pero ahora quiero volver a níger
para casarme y vivir allí
otro tipo de desencanto vive inmigrantes
argelinos que si bien llegaron al viejo
continente atravesando la costa española
no han logrado cumplir el anhelado sueño
europeo muchos están de manera irregular
en francia y atrapados en medio de una
crisis sanitaria
vinimos aquí para trabajar no para
dormir afuera ni para robar pero no hay
trabajo con fronteras cerradas sin
trabajo y sin papeles se sienten entre
la espada y la pared con respecto a las
autoridades inmigrante irregular que
regresa a argelia puede ser condenado a
prisión a pesar de los obstáculos y la
desilusión son mil de las personas que
siguen huyendo de sus países
solamente en 2020 40 mil 106 migrantes
cruzaron el mediterráneo frente a los 26
mil 168 del año anterior